[موسيقى] أجنبية
حقًا من الأدرينالين بالطبع لديك
القليل من القلق ، لكنني كنت
أشعر بالقشعريرة تمامًا ولكني حرفياً
شعرت بالقشعريرة أشعر وكأنني طفل صغير
[موسيقى] ،
كما تعلمون ، كان الأمر مبهجًا ، أعني
أنه ليس أمرًا
شريرًا ، أليس كذلك
إنه أمر مريح ، أعني أنه كان من
المهم حقًا أن تقلعني وتهبط ، لذا
لا يوجد مثل هذا النوع من الأحمق ، إنه
حرفيًا شديد السلاسة ولا يمكنني
انتظار المستقبل ، فأنا متحمس جدًا
[موسيقى]
أجنبية
أعتقد أننا  ابدأ بتوصيل
الأطعمة والخدمات ربما عن طريق الطائرات بدون طيار
واه وأعتقد أنك تعرف الآن
أعتقد أنها تكتب لدور
اليوم للمطار ولكني متشوق لمعرفة متى
نذهب إلى الجوار والحي ، لذلك
دعونا نجعل كل شيء على ما يرام.
أشعر وكأنني عمري 15 عامًا ،
لقد خرجت للتو من Star Wars
وركبت دراجتهم ، أعني أنها رائعة
[موسيقى]
أجنبية